auch nicht wenn sie jetzt überfordert
mit der situation
[Musik]
mal gucken wie oft ich meinen kommentar
ich hab hunger litt was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video ja leute ich hoffe natürlich euch
geht's gut ich habe es wirklich sehr
sehr oft gelesen dass ihr euch das mal
wünscht und zwar habe ich ja jetzt in
letzter zeit öfter mal die schlechtesten
restaurants die schlechtesten
friseurläden die schlechteste nacht
keine ahnung jetzt kommen noch einiges
holprig zu ein paar sachen habe ich halt
auch schon vor gedreht weil ich jetzt ab
sonntag im skiurlaub bin ja und heute
habe ich mal was anderes vor und zwar
gehen wir heute nicht in das
schlechteste restaurant sondern einfach
nur das beste
also muss man eigentlich nicht viel zu
erklären
leute ich habe mich hingesetzt und habe
wirklich jedes restaurant mir angeguckt
ich habe mir sämtliche rezensionen
durchgelesen und habe dabei zwei
faktoren berücksichtigt das restaurant
was sie heute ausgewählt haben hat eine
bewertung von 4,8 sternen also fast vom
sterne fast volle bewertung das ist
natürlich der erste punkt auf den ich
jetzt habe der zweite war dann weil es
gibt schon restaurants die fünf sterne
haben die sind dann allerdings nur zwei
oder drei mal bewertet und das dann
vermutlich auch noch von den besitzern
oder freunden und das zählt ja dann
nicht also ich hab wirklich geguckt
welches restaurant ist extrem gut
bewertet und hat auch noch extrem viele
bewertungen damit man auch weiß okay das
ist wirklich von kunden bewertet worden
und welches restaurant das ist das zeige
ich euch sehr gerne jetzt wird und zwar
handelt es sich um dieses ressort
ristorante getrost gab also ich glaube
ich italienisch oder so auch steht ja
auch jetzt fragt ihr euch sicherlich hey
wieso sollst nicht zensiert also ich hab
mir gedacht was muss ich jetzt zensieren
ich meine selbst wenn es leute sehen die
dort arbeiten
schöne grüße war auf jeden fall glaube
ich ganz leider deswegen mache ich jetzt
einfach mal nicht er ist ja auch gute
werbung für die ich muss nämlich
fairerweise sagen deswegen sehen meine
haare gleich plötzlich auch wieder lange
aus dem video wir waren ja schon essen
zusammen ich wollte meiner freundin
haben das schon aufgenommen und ja das
mache ich jetzt halt im nachhinein ich
glaube allzu lange gibt es das
allerdings noch nicht 113 google
rezensionen sind jetzt schon viele
natürlich aber auch nicht so viele und
wenn man sich die hier so anschaut das
sind halt wirklich hier oben diese top
bewertung alles fünf sterne jeder war
zufrieden oder das haben wir auch
gemacht dass hier haben wir uns noch als
nachtisch gegönnt nehmen wollte man doch
nicht muss die schokolade auf jeden fall
ich will jetzt gar nicht zu viel
verraten wie es dort genau was für
gegessen haben wie teuer ist vor allem
war das sieht jetzt ich wünsche euch
viel spaß schreibt sehr gerne weitere
ideen und wünsche was ich als nächstes
mal testen soll natürlich auch sehr
gerne das beste oder schlechteste von
irgendwas schreibt immer in die
kommentare lassen doch nach oben da dann
machen wir das und jetzt geht's los
lecker ist so leute auf geht's marie
kommt heute auch mit also wir sind zu
zweit ist ja auch ganz gut weil das kann
man ja so als schönes romantisches
dinner bezeichnen oder
also wir sind jetzt auf dem weg in die
stadt
wie gesagt ist schon ein bisschen später
nie habe ich glaube ich noch gar nicht
gesagt keine ahnung und das restaurant
befindet sich wieder sehr zentral immer
gespannt was er lust auf italienisch
und eine erwartung genauso wie meine
aber soll auf der zülpicher strafen
lagen mitten im studentenviertel
eindeutig sagen nicht begehen wenn jetzt
aber nicht mitwächst blöd
so leute wir sind da dafür eine ist das
restaurant und jetzt wird mal wieder auf
jetzt mal wieder auf das handy und was
machst du heute mal oder das sieht aber
gut aus ist auch ordentlich teuer hier
für den vierer oder so nach und nach
alles gut fasst oder hängig
[Musik]
leute das hier ist jetzt unsere
speisekarte hier oder was die hälfte
danach habe ich noch nie gehört
nicht irgendwann was das heißt ich davon
gar nichts das mal keine ahnung
14 28 ja das muss aber auch wissen was
er tun
[Musik]
danke
ein kalb stecken ja ja so seine ist da
ist auch drittel so genau nehmen und was
ist mit der situation
ich habe keine ahnung
also ich glaube nicht dass das so so so
vorgesehen ist laut urteil war hier eine
richtige szene restaurant
so leute maria hat übrigens hier
sonnenreichen und ich ein alkoholfreies
bier
achso hier also das ist kein alkohol
drin
[Musik]
cool
aber ist nicht alles auf einmal aus bei
der operation fans mich wahrscheinlich
habe ich mal liegt ich habe einfach nur
durch viel kartoffeln somit vier
kartoffelscheiben
mal gucken wie oft ich in den
kommentaren ich habe hunger
gut ist dass wir für boni
das sieht aus wie das fenster für mich
war raus bei uns mit fahrrad loretta
ausgerufen
also ich möchte mein lieblingsgericht
lama war auf fünf alltag oder
nachzuschießen
damit alles sehr klein und fein marien
nach die ganze hätte ich bin mir total
underdressed aber ich finde es
eigentlich gut aber man muss auch sagen
die toilette ist jetzt nicht so sauber
wieder drin an die medius hose in
übrigens männer kloos aus und meist auch
noch was drin also es nicht so gut also
dass wenn ich also wir immer abspielen
kann sollte jetzt kann man noch einen
nachtisch ausspielen
nehmen sie haben zu drücken mit hartz iv
aus la santa cecilia heißt panna cotta
und cremes können sie das ganze was
aussuchen oder panna cotta nehmen oder
immerhin hatte ich mir kirchengut muss
muss das jetzt zerstört
wir können den zweiten pokal einnahmen
muss runter damit ich frag mich gerade
warum ich mich auf diesen bildern dahin
alex der restauranttester bin jetzt ein
geschäft
heute haben wir sind jetzt wieder im
auto ich muss sagen dass erstmal
wirklich sehr sehr gut also ich habe
selten so gut ist dass also es war alles
perfekt eigentlich man erwähnt einziges
manko soll ich mal so
also muss man schon teuer das werde ich
nicht gedacht dass es so toll ist und
bei mir war die ganze flieger meinem
platz noch mal ganz schnell also ich
habe insgesamt 80 euro bezahlt +56
trinkgeld man gibt ja immer so 10% wir
haben dann frisches wasser 7 eur 43 50
eur 1 7 euro nudel 20 euro
manche 27 euro und danach sich neun euro
deswegen ist 80 euro an sich keine
nachvollziehbare preis und war halt
schon etwas teurer abend bereits gedacht
sagen wir es mal so wir haben insgesamt
für alles zusammen 73 50 natürlich
hatten wir auch noch nach der stelle
auch noch mal zehn euro kostet ich finde
für so ist das auch mal okay aber es ist
natürlich schon teuer
prof
und spaghetti und ich habe keine ahnung
wie das zubereitet hat der karte hat
sich mit seinem riesen
ja weil das ein gutes restaurant ist das
ist das bestbewertete restaurant
mithalten kannst du dir und handelsleute
also das war's mit dem video ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen lasse mir sehr
gerne dicke nach oben da schreibt
weitere ideen für die schlechtesten oder
besten ist uns in die kommentare und wir
sind uns morgen oder übermorgen wieder
die leute gucken uns hier alle an als
wären wir die größten hoden haut rein
das war es von uns nicht aus